One thing that's much easier to interpret from our line plot
is any trend in the data.
We can see here the short dips in attendance,
that occur fairly regularly with some period, these might be weekends.
And we see another fairly large drop towards the end of the year.
And while the flu may be apparent in the tabular data due to the sharp and
somewhat extended decline in attendance.
It is much easier to spot with the visual representation of the data.
And other more subtle patterns, such as weekend dips,
may be impossible to notice from the tabular representation alone.
This is due to the fact that is it not dipped to zero or close to zero.
Let's say because there is weekend classes or
extracurricular activities, and is only apparent when you
look at the pattern over time of the periodic activity of ups and downs.
Let's say, however,
that I want to know how many students were in school on January 14.
Since we're interesting in simply looking up
a specific attendance on a specific day,
the table is much easier to understand as we can look to the exact row we need.
And look across to
the single number that represents the attendance for that day.
Often this behavior of drilling down to a specific datum,
in this case January 14.
Can be incorporated into a visual graphic through animation and
annotation which is actually what Dimple.js,
the library we will use in just a second allows us to do.
But in this example of a static chart is much easier to
look up the attendance for a single day in the table.
Rather than have to look at a potentially large and
nuanced plot of days and go across to attendance.